so speaking of
uh the finiteness of our existence
on on in this world uh
so on the front of psychedelics and
teaching you lessons
as a researcher as a human being um
what have you learned about death about
mortality
about the finiteness of our existence
are you yourself
afraid of death and how has your
view do you ponder it and has your view
of your immortality changed
with the research you've done yeah yeah
so
i do ponder it and uh are you afraid of
death probably on a daily basis i ponder
it
i would i'd have to pick it apart more
and say
yeah i am afraid of dying like the the
process of dying
um i'm not afraid of being dead i mean
i'm not afraid of i think it was pin
gillette that said uh
and he may have gotten it from someone
else but like i'm not afraid of the year
you know 1862 before i existed i'm not
afraid of the year 22
62 after i'm gone like it's gonna be
fine but
yeah you know dying like i'd i'd be
lying if i said i wasn't afraid of
you know dying and so there's both like
the process of dying like yeah it's
usually not good
it'd be nice if it was after many many
years and just sort of you know
i'd rather not fall you know die in my
sleep i'd rather kind of be conscious
but sort of just die
fade out with old age maybe but but like
you know just
being in an accident and like you know
horrible diseases i've seen enough
loved ones it's like yeah this is not
good this is enough to be
you know i'd like to say that i'm i'm
peaceful and sort of balanced enough
that i'm not concerned at all but no
like yeah i'm afraid of dying
um but i'm also concerned about um i
think about family like i
i'm really i'm afraid or at least con
you know concerned about
like not being there like with a
three-year-old not
being there not being there for for him
and my wife
and my mom the rest the rest of her life
i'm concerned about not
i'm concerned more about like the harm
that it would cause if i left
prematurely
and then kind of even bigger along the
lines of some of the stuff that ford
thinking we've been talking about i
think
maybe way too much about just like and
i'll never know the answer
so even if i live to you know 120 like
but like
i want to know as much as i can but like
how is this going to work out like as
humans
are we and a big one i think is are we
gonna and i don't think unfortunately
i'm gonna
learn it in my lifetime even if i
live to a ripe old age but well i don't
know is this gonna work out like
are we gonna escape the planet i think
that's one of the biggies like are we
gonna
like the survival of the speed like i
think the next
like the time we're in now it's like
with the nuclear weapons with pandemics
and with um uh i mean we're gonna get to
the point where anyone can
can build a hydrogen bomb like you know
it's like
you just like the exact or engineer like
the you know something that's a million
times worse than covet and then you
spread it it's like yeah we're getting
to this period
of and then not to mention climate
change you know it's like although i
think
that's not there's probably going to be
surviving humans with that regard
you know but it could be really bad but
these
existential threats i think the only
real guarantee that we're going to get
another
you name it thousand million whatever
years is like
diversity diver diversify our portfolio
get get off the planet
you know um don't leave this one
hopefully we keep you know but like
and i you know it's like either we're
gonna get snuffed out
like really quickly or we're gonna
like if we if we reach that point and
it's gonna be over the next
like 100 200 years like like we're
probably going to survive like
like until like i mean you know like our
son
like and even beyond that like like
we're probably going to be talking about
millions and millions of years it's like
and we're we're i don't know in terms of
the planet four billion years into this
and depending on how you count our
species you know we're
you know we're millions of years into
this and it's like it's this is like the
point of the
relay race where we can really screw up
so that would make you feel pretty good
when you're on your
deathbed 120 years old and there's
something hopeful about
there's a colony starting up on mars and
it's like
yeah titan like whatever you know like
yeah like that we have these
colonies out there that would tell me
like
yeah then at least we'd be good until
like the
you know hopefully probably until the
the
the sun goes red giant you know what i
mean yeah rather than oh like
20 years from now when there's some
someone with their finger on the nuclear
button that just
you know misperceives a you know the
radar
you know like the signal they they think
russia's attacking they're really not or
china and like that's probably how a
nuclear accident
war is going to start rather than you
know or the
like i said these other horrible things
does it not make you sad that
uh you won't be there if uh we are
successful uh proliferating throughout
the
observable universe that you won't be
there to
experience any of it just yeah you go
death right
it's the death because you're still
gonna die and it's still gonna be over
right that's uh you know ernest becker
and those folks really emphasize
the terror of death that if we're honest
we'll discover if we search within
ourselves which is like
this thing is going to be over most of
our existence
is uh based on the illusion
that is going to go forever and when you
sort of realize
it's actually going to be over like
today like
i might murder you at the end of this
conversation
uh it might be over today or like you
go on going home this might be your last
day in this earth
and it's
i mean uh like pondering that and i i
suppose
i suppose one thing to be me i i i
if i were to push back it's interesting
is you actually i think you see
comfort in the sadness of how
unfortunate it would be for your family
to not have you
because the really even even the deepers
yes but that's the simple fear even the
deeper terror is like
like this this thing doesn't last
forever
like i think uh i don't know they're
like if it's hard to put the right words
to it but it feels like
that's not truly acknowledged
by us by each of each of us
yeah i think this is the i mean getting
back to the psychedelics in terms of the
people in our our work with cancer
patients who
um we had psilocybin sessions to help
them and it did substantially help them
um the vast majority um in terms of
dealing with these existential issues
and i think
you know it's something we i could say
that i really feel that i've come along
in that
both like being with folks who have died
that are close to me and then also that
work
i think are the two biggies and sort of
like
you know i think i've come along and
that that sort of acceptance of this
like like it's not going to last
um any whether at the personal level or
even at the species levels like at some
point all the stars are going to fade
out
and it's going to be the realm of which
is going to be the vast majority if it
can
unless there's a big crunch which
apparently doesn't seem likely
like most of the universe there's this
blink of an eye that's happening right
now that life is even possible
like the era of stars so it's like we're
going to fade out at some point
like you know and you know then we get
at this level of consciousness and like
okay
maybe there is life after death maybe
there's maybe times an illusion maybe
like that part i'm ready for like i'm
i'm like
you know like strap that that would be
really great and i'm looking i'm not
afraid of that at all it's like even if
it's
just strange like if i could push a
button to enter that door
i mean i'm not gonna you know die you're
not gonna kill myself but it's like
if i could take a peek at what that
reality is or choose at the end of my
life if i could choose of
entering into a universe where there is
an afterlife of something completely
unknown versus one where there's none i
think i'd say well let's see what's
behind that
that's a true scientist way of thinking
if there's a door
you're excited about opening it and
going in right
but i am attracted to this idea like
like you know it's and i recognize it's
easier said than done
to say i'm okay with not existing yeah
it's like the real test is like okay
check me on my deathbed
you know it's like it's oh yeah so it'd
be all right it's beautiful thing and
the humility of surrendering and
i really hope and i think i'd probably
be more likely to be in that realm right
now
than i would like or check me when i get
a terminal cancer diagnosis and i really
hope i'm more in that realm but i
i know enough about human nature to know
that like i don't wanna i can't really
speak to that because i haven't been in
that situation
and i think there can be a beauty to
that and the transcendence of like yeah
and you know it was it was beautiful not
just despite all that
but because of that because ultimately
there's going to be nothing
and because we came from nothing and we
dealt with all this the fact that
there was still beauty
and truth and connection like that
you know like it just it's a beautiful
thing
but i i hope i'm in that it's easy to
say that now
you